je propose tout de suite de revenir sur
cet homme recherché mort ou vif selon
les propos de george bush le
milliardaire d'origine saoudienne
oussama ben laden qui seraient les
preuves sont irréfutables responsable
des attentats du 11 septembre 1971 col
pelle à tarte et pattes d'éléphant la
famille ben laden est en vacances en
suède
elle est nombreuse riche et oussama
alors âgée de 14 ans a tout pour devenir
un playboy oisifs de la jet set
internationale
trente ans plus tard il représente
l'islamisme le plus fondamentalistes
l'ennemi numéro un des américains
avant d'être le nom de l'homme le plus
recherché de la planète
ben laden était celui d'une famille
respectée le père d'oussama d'origine
yéménite a fait fortune dans le bâtiment
en arabie saoudite
à sa mort en 72 il laisse à ses enfants
des millions de dollars et un empire
selon ses volontés osama poursuivre des
études d'ingénieur et d'économie dans
cette université saoudienne
il rencontre alors abdallah azzam un
théologien d'origine palestinienne qu'il
considère comme un maître et se mettre
fondamentalistes estime que tout bon
musulman doit aller aider les frères
afghans dans leur guerre sainte contre
l'envahisseur rue
nous sommes en 79 oussama ben laden a 22
ans
les moudjahidine le fascine il décide de
récolter dans les pays du golfe
l'argent nécessaire à leur cause grâce
aux relations de sa famille il amassé
une fortune avec son maître abdallah
azzam il crée ensuite un grand réseau de
recrutement et d'entraînement sous
l'oeil bienveillant de la cia qui
soutient les moudjahidine au nom de la
guerre froide puis ben laden abandonne
son maître et crée sa propre
organisation al-qaïda imposer au monde
sa conception d'islam devient pour lui
une mission divine
une fois un obus de mortier russe est
tombée juste à ses pieds et il m'a dit
qu'à ce moment très précis il a ressenti
une sérénité intense qu'il a interprété
comme un signe religieux à la bombe n'a
pas explosé
je crois que cela vaut pour marquer et
qu'il s'agit d'un moment clé dans sa vie
1989 les derniers chars russes quittent
l'afghanistan mais pour ben laden le
combat continue son nouvel ennemi sera
l'ami d'hier l'amérique en 91
la guerre du golfe éclate les américains
s'installent en arabie saoudite pour
déloger saddam hussein du koweït est
bombardée lire 1 ben laden par
s'installer au soudan avec ses quatre
femmes et 13 enfants
il enrage contre les états unis
à chaque fois qu'on s'est rencontré il
était obsédé par trois ou quatre choses
et marque les troupes américaines qui
contaminait la terre sainte d'arabie on
se trouve la mecque et médine et voulait
renverser les régimes arabes pro
américain qui selon lui une applique pas
la loi islamique
il était aussi bouleversée par la mort
de milliers d'enfants irakiens sous la
sanction des nations unies mais il ne
défendait pas saddam hussein le jet est
évidemment il reproche aussi aux
américains leur soutien à israël dans
cette fatwa qu'il signe en 98 il annonce
la création du front islamique
internationale pour le djihad contre les
juifs et les chrétiens
il est du devoir de tout musulman
écrit-il de tuer les américains et leurs
alliés
l'été suivant les ambassades américaines
au kenya et en tanzanie explose 224
morts sur une dizaine d'attentats commis
depuis 92 plane l'ombre de ben laden
che guevara de l'islam pour certains
terroristes sanguinaires pour les autres
ben laden est souvent soupçonné sans
qu'on arrive à savoir si les
commanditaires ou seulement inspirateur
un guide qui n'aurait plus besoin de
donner d'ordres pour déclencher de
meurtrières initiative
à propos du 11 septembre les enquêteurs
disent avoir les preuves indéniables de
son implication en ce cas l'inoffensif
adolescents saoudien est devenu en
trente ans le pire terroriste de
l'histoire de l'humanité